يمكنك خلع قناعك دون
ارتدائه في جميع أنحاء الولايات المتحدة.الأطفال الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين 5 و
11 عامًا يشمرون عن سواعدهم للحصول على
لقاح covid19 الآن
أعرف أن جسدي
قوي بما يكفي لأنني حصلت على اللقطة
الآن لن يتم اعتبار الأطفال
محصنين بالكامل حتى عامين  بعد أسابيع من
تناول جرعتهم الثانية من فايزر ، حيث يجب
أن تفصل كل جرعة عن 21 يومًا على الأقل ، يجب على الآباء والأمهات الذين يتطلعون إلى
الحماية بحلول عيد الميلاد في كوانزا ، أن
يكون الموعد النهائي في 19 نوفمبر للحصول على
الجرعة الأولى و 10 ديسمبر
للجرعة الثانية ، يجب على الآباء
استشارة أطباء الأطفال.
يتشاور أطباء الأسرة مع
الصيدلي الخاص بهم وسيكونون قادرين على
معرفة مكان الحصول على هذا
اللقاح المحدد لأطفالهم من 5 إلى 11.
ابتداءً من 8 نوفمبر ،
يقول البيت الأبيض إن برنامج لقاح الأطفال سيكون
جاهزًا بالكامل بحلول نهاية
يقول المسؤولون في الأسبوع إن الآباء يمكنهم أيضًا
التحقق من مكان توفر اللقاحات في
منطقتهم من خلال تسجيل الدخول إلى اللقاحات.
رمال
العيادات المجتمعية الكثير منا قلق
بشأن ما يحدث عندما يصبح الطقس
باردًا حيث يذهب الجميع إلى الداخل حيث
تبدأ هذه النوافذ في الإغلاق في المدارس
وتزداد التهوية سوءًا بعد
تلقيح الأطفال يساعد على منع
خبراء الصحة الذين يقولون إن الحصول على الأطفال
التطعيم هو المفتاح لتفادي
زيادة الشتاء المحتملة في الحصول على
موسم عطلة آمن من أجل دقيقة صحية
أنا ماندي غيثر